now
it can be a fatal disease to your brand
new puppy or kitten parvo virus innate
on your side tonight we connect with a
local veterinarian on the steps you need
to take to keep that puppy or kitten
remaining
dr jamie ogenstein of oasis animal
hospital in henderson says over the past
five years vets across the country are
seeing new cases of parvovirus emerge
just last month 30 dogs in northern
michigan died from a mysterious illness
that had parva-like symptoms initial
parvo tests came back negative and then
ultimately came back as parvo parvo is
been changing recently vets monitor
outbreaks in other states as it's just a
matter of time before they work their
way across the country because we're
such a transient society and it's very
easy for an animal to pick up parvo they
get it by ingestion
right so they come across it they step
in it they lick their paw but they
ingest the virus gets into their gi
tract it actually attacks
the gi tract gets absorbed into the
bloodstream
from there it actually goes the immune
system actually suppresses the immune
system the virus causes vomiting fever
severe diarrhea and extreme dehydration
which can kill an animal within two to
three days so prompt veterinary
attention is crucial as is a complete
set of vaccines for your puppy or kitten
the new recommendations are they'll be
vaccinated out to 20 weeks
so their last vaccine should be at 20
weeks of age and parvo is actually the
reason that that recommendation came
about
until your puppy or kitten is fully
vaccinated by 20 weeks minimize their
exposure to other people and animals
keep it to people you know who are
healthy other pets that are healthy etc
until your puppy or kitten's immune
system matures